[Music]
sorry master got announced this games a
little more succinct RTS well compared
to everything Eric yes you like
Starcraft I do did you play the original
a lot yeah I played the original and
brood war a lot in high school and I
think I felt like as I was growing up at
least for me I played a lot more RTS
games than I do now yeah I don't think
that outside of when Starcraft 2 first
came out I've really touched any RTS
since back then with command & Conquer
and Starcraft and stuff like that in
Warcraft so it's interesting to see it
get remastered but for the longest time
this rumors been kind of lingering and
kind of felt like it was gonna happen
yes I'm just interested to see if people
still care I guess I mean like when that
game came out and maybe this reflects
your experience or not but like a lot of
land party situations around Starcraft
you know like I used to play magic and
I'd go to my local like game shop to
like you know sit down and play some
cards but there was also like a row of
12 computers and like this was the game
that I really identified with as you
know competitive PC gaming like at first
like yeah there was kind of either was
like quake and stuff back then but this
but this really kicked it off and
definitely took off more than something
like command & Conquer I mean there were
so many different Red Alert and
community honker games that like they
all kind of blend it together but
Starcraft always had its own real strong
identity and for all the series for all
the series that Blizzard lizard has
exploited this one hasn't really been I
feel like it hasn't been tapped like
Starcraft two's been out now for what
six seven years thinks something like
that reexpansion three expansions and
that's that's kind of it and there was
two expansions for this right yeah yeah
like brood war and yeah no just
whispered words yeah I feel like there's
a lot of potential maybe people missed
out on this game back in the day for the
longest time I was joking they're gonna
do the next MMO for Blizzard it's gonna
be space of StarCraft you know person
shooter game ghosts ghosts yeah yeah
yeah I never officially got cancelled
but it's not out how many years later
ten so it's probably not gonna happen
it might though
star crap yeah just for running through
the specs base game and brood war that
is included it's gonna be 4k Ultra High
Definition which they showed during that
trailer yeah I mean they show the the
wipe kind of and they showed it to the
wider resolution too right
and then it'll have matchmaking we do
have a question from Bob Jones who's at
GameSpot regular but on Twitter he was
asking how much will it cost and can I
play it offline they have not announced
pricing yet they said it's gonna be out
this summer so I'm assuming we'll see
more soon we don't know anything either
in terms of playing it offline I would
assume you can play the campaign offline
I don't think you yeah I mean I was I
mean a matchmake but that and maybe if
you could LAN possibly yeah anymore
that's true nobody lands it was for me
LAN was a halo and then Warcraft 3 the
mods tower defense mob
winter mall that was that was the best
there's the peak of my nish tower
defense hobby and then SAS Creed
Revelations came along and had
telephones so ruined it for me
I have a question for you sure alright I
mean Peter you're talking about
Starcraft kind of kicking off a
competitive piece like what we think of
as competitive PC gaming does going back
to it have the same effect like does
returning to it have the same value or
does it have like what is the value
there I think that it's not really gonna
get that many new people cuz you
probably just played Starcraft 2 if
you're gonna play an RTS I think it's
the nostalgic feeling that like a lot of
people will have with Starcraft and in
some people's minds they actually like
Starcraft in brood war more than excuse
me more than Starcraft 2 so I could see
that potentially coming into play maybe
eSports I don't know they're gonna try
they're gonna try but they still have
yeah I think I I think that they'll try
because they had a lot of Starcraft 2
up-and-coming pros and pros that came
over from the brood war see sure so
maybe they'll be more like invitationals
or kind of like one thing kind of things
like that but it's hard to say I did do
the land thing like you did with
Starcraft and
and counter-strike those two were the
games ping-pong between if we went to a
LAN cafe and I don't know I don't it's
it's a weird timing I'd rather have it
was just a funny way to say cafe yeah
that's like the hardest side quest in
that game it takes all three days I know
don't bring up that goddamn starcraft
conversation for those who don't know Oh
jean-luc psyche our producer in the back
room said that the trailer did sail and
support sweet so for those who don't
know what did broodwar do to the base
game it basically added a bunch of Units
essentially that changed the way the
game works so lurker was a huge one
which is like a c gene unit for the sir
that you know could burrow and then you
it shoots out kind of like a line of
spikes essentially but you'd have to
have observers or you'd have to scan it
so it made you think more about those
kind of things Dark Templar 4 for the
Protoss so it just changed how you
thought about the game I guess because
you had to worry about all these cloaked
units that you didn't have to before and
kind of adapter strategies to that medic
was huge for Terran because it could
heal your stemmed Marines so it's just
more of like a meta thing for the game
that's kind of how it changed but I
think brood war made that game a lot
better yeah I mean we were saying when
this gun announced and we were talking
about like halo wars 2 came out this
year as well and it was kind of you know
lackluster Kelly reviewed it did you
give it a 6 out of 10 yeah yeah I didn't
love it it was an okay game but it
didn't like it's a Halo fan and RTS fan
I was kind of hoping for a better blend
of both but I think they kind of went in
both directions didn't have a good
singular identity I also wanted to talk
about the like kind of current state of
the RTS genre cuz there aren't a lot
releasing there's a decent amount and
there are some cool interesting games
coming out especially last year but it's
nothing like huge I don't know if
Starcraft remastered will be enough to
like kick-start another generation of
these games by the way I mean ideally it
would but I don't think it will but
forget you live in an ideal world yeah I
we need an optimist sitting next to
crummy curmudgeon oak ruff sorry that's
a Twitter handle it my games my fan
crummy creme I didn't and I think it's
you stay you were saying but I mean as a
if there was a remastered that I really
want from Blizzard it's actually Diablo
2 yeah I don't think it'll happen but
like everyone's or not everyone's but
some of the people in the office were
immediately like oh they did Starcraft
remastered let's just do Diablo 2
remastered because I spent so much time
playing that game and I think that would
be really cool I thought maybe they'd do
it last year Blizzcon because it was the
20th anniversary for Diablo and I don't
know we'll see I'd rather have that than
Starcraft remastered but that's just me
it's just weird that going back to the
RTS stuff I mean last year was total war
Warhammer Ash's the singularity
homeworld deserts of Carrick what was
the offworld trading company Soren
Johnson who did who's Ally designer and
sieve for he released the off-road
training company which is really good
game was one of my it was like top it
was a really good game last year and
then Dawn of War 3 is pretty close on
the horizon there there's a decent
amount of RTS games coming out in that
space but it doesn't seem like the
audience is there anymore to make them
huge right like you mentioned command &
Conquer I have that like 15th
anniversary edition through origin and
it's like 18 games or something red
alert 2 is one of my favorite games
period and I play that every once in a
while still but I played homeworld last
year that game was great Ashley the
singularity was cool and the the scale
that it portrayed you could zoom out and
it would you could command like
battalions and also single units and see
like an entire planet technically
impressive off world training company
was a cool take on economy and how that
could transfer into the real-time
strategy genre but I don't know there's
nothing that's really you know you see
shooters look at a watershed year yeah
16 from home alone - if you're into that
I think you know the program sorry one
more one more
herkermer Homolka from Congo there we
got considered sorry
[Music]
there was certainly a time when like
redwood studios was like pumping out new
command & Conquer games like changing up
settings and like adding a lot of new
units and stuff where it felt like you
could really pay attention in the RTS
genre and get something new out of it
every couple months or something to look
forward to but gaming as a whole like
especially on PC has sort of blown up in
so many ways now because it's borrowing
a lot from consoles you know it RTS
genre has kind of disappeared but I
don't I don't think it'll ever be like a
huge mainstream success for like an RTS
game is like upfront but I think it'll
always be around you know and you just
have fewer players but to see off-road
trading company come out and do
something that really surprised a lot of
people like that'd be cool to see I
think more experimentation within the
genre yes we had for home to live maybe
like the early 2000s there seems like
every property that mean I you know
early 2000s but I mean battle for
middle-earth came out actually like
those games they kind of felt too much
into the rock-paper-scissor formula of
you know simpler RTS games
I mean Halo Wars is a great like yeah I
was gonna say like Halo Wars is very
much the the pared down simplified
version and I actually did like the
combination of like oh here's stuff for
Halo fans and here's like a simpler RTS
thing I think it's good if you don't
want the barrier to entry that a lot of
RTS games have right um but it's it's
just like it's not doing anything new or
different or interesting to keep your
attention yeah
that's the biggest problem for me with
that yeah I was playing homeworld
finally late last year and this was I
mean a couple months for Halo Wars to
came out and that was actually gearbox
did that with gearbox released it yeah
and I was it was a good RTS it was they
redid they took home roll from space and
brought it to like the desert planet
where it's supposedly started it was a
prequel to all those if you were into
those games back in the day but I mean
turn-based strategy has been flourishing
but you have XCOM you have civilization
and I'm just naming Firaxis stuff right
now but of course you have like Fire
Emblem you have well well but that's
super different but it's still like it's
such a integral part of like the RPG
space off the top my head I know banner
saga just had a collection at least you
should play those games you had haven't
yet
those are next MOX one no yes about to
be but are they it really [ __ ] I think
it's on its way okay but like in the
next week if it's not already yet yeah
so you should play those if you play an
Xbox one and haven't played banner saga
one or two yet not RTS
eh I also just kind of I'm wondering if
there is gonna be like that Renaissance
here for RTS like you said it's never
gonna be as widespread as shooters and
last year kind of shooters were always
be around but last year it was a lot of
innovation in that genre and you said I
don't think RTS has the same ones more
than shooters - it's just so you know
like games like Mass Effect like you
know just are like bigger like grand
scale games that's maybe have an hour an
hour PG element to them or something but
sort of these grander adventures because
when you're managing like little units
on a field like that doesn't feel maybe
as exciting to a lot of people I think
right off the bat you really have to get
through the barrier to entry that Callie
was mentioning for a lot of these games
to experience what makes them so great
they don't have that instant
gratification yeah I think that's
probably the biggest barrier I also
think - I think someone in twitch chat
I think it's console hot 92 had
mentioned - that with the kind of
flourishing of MOBAs yeah like you know
dota 2 league of Legends maybe Harless
geez here's a storm sorry
hot same acronym maybe a lot of the
people that used to play RTS games
because you know that though dota
basically came out from Warcraft right 2
or 3 from 3 dreams and maybe a lot of
those players have kind of transitioned
over to MOBAs right and so because of
that you're losing kind of like your
player base for RTS games as well yeah
yeah that's a good point yeah I mean
like I said if you pay attention there
are decent mount of RTS games coming out
and they're of high quality a few my
really liked homeworld for him played
that yet if you're like a Halo fan kind
of passing fan of RTS Halo Wars - might
satisfy that itch yeah I mean yeah like
I gave it us I didn't hate it so it's
yes but for all you know kind of waiting
it like go playoff world trading company
that game is awesome and it's really
cool it like I said it's the lead
designer of civilization 4 so he took
the economy aspects of civilization
games he played those and kind of made
it into a real-time strategy game on
Mars your founding you're selling Mars
with these corporations and it's a
really really engaging and fun and more
intense than you might think in an
economy based game right way let us know
if we missed any RTS games sure we did I
know we did let us know which ones
you've played throughout the years which
ones you might want to see rematch
sir just like Starcraft is getting with
its summer release coming from Blizzard
again we will update you more with a
price and the actual specific release
date when we find out
[Music]